[Music]  baby all right  I promise  home to Daddy you meet you the bargain  was that we raise this child together  and you will not let me in you asked me  to leave behind everything that truly  nothing to me oh this wonderful darling  wish away  you couldn't look at Brianna  now say him what you want from me I want  to know when you're gonna come back from  the past I've come home you were under  arrest  no put him in the irons you spoke to you  of my wife is that he was dead  I said she was gone she's still a con we  have to establish Jamie's alive  the must be records we will find him  [Music]  twenty years ago like shut the door on  the past  and it was the hottest thing I've ever  done  I found it I want to come back  [Music]  you